en las montañas de chiapas el pequeño
andrés golpea con un martillo en la roca
durante horas con la esperanza de
encontrar una pieza de ámbar por la que
le pueden pagar a su padre de 1 a 5
dólares desde marzo empezó a trabajar en
la mina a tiempo completo gana apenas
unas monedas que servirán para comprar
alimentos para su familia la escuela de
andrés lleva cerrada casi todo el año
desde que la pandemia de kobe 19 obligó
a los alumnos a quedarse en casa y si el
papá va a la milpa val cafetal va a la
mina el niño no va a quedar en casa pues
nada más
sin hacer nada mirando para ellos en
edad que quede mirando televisión si
tiene televisión pues es como que
estuviera perdiendo el tiempo
nació en otro poblado de chiapas
agustina ayuda a sus hijos a leer textos
en una cama que sirve de escritorio sin
embargo sienten no estar a la altura de
lo que ellos requieren dices pongo las
tareas estoy poniendo de una tarea así
para que vayan vayan
recordando pues pero no es igual como un
maestro yo soy un campesino no puedo
enseñar mucho a mis hijos
la cepal indica que méxico es el segundo
país en américa latina después de brasil
en donde más trabajo infantil hay cerca
de 23 millones de menores de edad
trabajan y casi el 90% de ellos lo hacen
en actividades peligrosas para su edad
en estos tiempos de crisis de trabajo en
un ángel se convierte en un mecanismo de
supervivencia para muchas familias no
pero si hay un aumento
en la pobreza
muchos más se van a ver empujados hacia
hacia el trabajo infantil si bien la ley
mexicana prohíbe que los menores de 14
años trabajen muchos de ellos deben
ayudar a sus familias con ingresos
precarios